mais j'en rigole parce que cette
histoire et j'atterris et je suis à
l'aéroport et puis un monsieur qui me
regardent il est avec son fils est si
tendue ne dis pas que je suis déjà connu
la fda ils arrivent ils arrivent il dit
au personnel ou la photo est ce que je
peux faire une photo sinon c'est la fin
de superstar et puis je fais la photo
avec son fils et à la fin de la photo
son fils iim une caresse comme ça et il
croit que j'étais sale en fait ils
comprenaient pas mal ma couleur oui et
non et il n'avait jamais vu deux noirs
j'étais le seul noir de toute la sicile
mois à l'âge de 17 ans ben voilà on
jeter des bananes à chaque fois que
j'avais le ballon on faisait le crillon
faisait le cri du singe mais mais tout
ce qu'ils savent mais voilà c'était ma
force et plus moi qui faisais les bruits
de sakba j'ai aujourd'hui je vais vous
mangez c'était ma détermination rien ne
pouvait m'arrêter tiens c'est ça c'est
certain la détermination parce que
parfois quand tu viens suis dit comme il
a dit tout ce qu'il a vécu son frère le
quartier tout ce qu'il a dû les épreuves
qu'il a dû traverser parfois quand le
succès arrive tu te plantes aussi c'est
ça c'est ça de terreur détermination est
ce que quand l'argent arrive vite
parfois tu te prête aussi parce que d'où
tu viens tu cram tout tu fais des
conneries et tu te fous tout seul dans
la mer entre les mauvaises rencontres
l'entourage à l'auto détermination à
lancer encore plus fort parce qu'elle
apparaîtra carrière trop l'a fait bravo
c'est encore pense être juste mais moi
je jouais au foot voilà par par passion
c'était je savais même pas qu'on pouvait
gagner de l'argent et mon premier
objectif j'ai dit au premier contrat
c'est d'acheter une maison à ma mère ça
c'était c'était mon objectif
alors quand on est joueur pro qu'on
gagne énormément d'argent comme ça est
ce que le regard des autres aussi
forcément émission je regarde des potes
des trucs cessé mais mais mais ils
changent mais tnt une vache à traire a
fait ça tous les gens qui sont autour de
toi ils t'aiment pas c'est parce que tu
leur donne à manger c'est pour ça que
l'entourage il ya tellement c'est un
monde de requins il ya des personnes qui
sont aujourd'hui en prison parce qu'ils
ont fait confiance à leur entourage moi
je connais les dégâts quand ils vont en
boîte ils sont là elles et des potes le
ramène des films et ça peut leur causer
des problèmes et c'est ça le problème
quand un argent trop tôt mais moi je me
disais j'ai joué pour la passion pas
pour être connu moi c'était sur le
terrain mais l'entourage
on parle pas des joueurs de paris à des
gens qui se font racketter et c'est
compliqué et il n'y a pas d' aide
psychologique à ça et c'est ça le gros
problème c'est pour ça que c'est on est
livrés à nous mêmes et puis tous les
joueurs de foot on n'a pas fait tous des
grandes études donc après on est on est
facile à influencer il faut dire la
vérité